[Music]
how do you reignite the British economy
right gentleman
today is your current real fitting task
at this Factory in Walsall they're
manufacturing the workers of tomorrow
Labor shortages are holding back
companies across the country I think
Marx what is currently surface grinding
to get the Downs of Tolerance but here
they train hundreds of Engineers young
and old the skills they need to fill the
gaps local businesses are are Furious
really that we've got this skill
shortages over recent years especially
if during the pandemic you saw a lot of
people in the main redundant furloughed
or realize there were such a point in
life where they could actually exit
engineering manufacturing and retire so
what we're trying to do here is Achieve
by reskilling them quickly to come back
into the sector
one of the big drivers of the UK labor
shortage is a rise in early retirement
the chancellor says he wants to get the
over 50s off the golf course and back
into jobs tomorrow's budget will raise
the tax-free pension allowance to 1.8
million pounds a financial carrot to
keep the already well off in work for
those enjoying a round of golf here it
could be a hard sell I don't think
anything would have made me delay
retirement I think there's a lot of
people who would probably like to retire
early and I think I would call myself
living in the Golden Age where I
actually could if you've paid until
pension for all those years and the way
that pensions are calculated it doesn't
make sense to stay on for a lot of
people you know most of us here are
probably in a fairly privileged position
but you know to a lot of people that
could make some changes like the pension
of change as possible in the budget that
will probably keep some people at work
but at the moment you know there may be
maybe retire
budget without a huge War chest to spend
so why choose this measure there are
huge differences inside the conservative
party about economics perhaps bigger
than any other policy area
the party simultaneously seems to want
lower taxes and higher growth and lower
borrowing and to spend money on leveling
up which is why it looks like tomorrow
Rishi sunac will go for the path of
political least resistance allowing
pensioners to take more money tax-free
effectively helping the Tory party base
a lot of money but not helping huge
numbers of people the proposed big
increase in the total amount you can
save into your pension pot tax-free will
make a big difference to some
individuals mainly richer households but
it won't increase the number of workers
overall significantly in fact some
people may retire earlier as a result of
it the things that will make more
difference are very welcome changes to
child care support within Universal
Credit and there are very big changes
being proposed in the disability benefit
system but those will take years to
implement the authors of this budget
don't expect it to be a game changer
business tax breaks to boost growth
assisting people back into work and
three months more help with energy bills
is Steady As She Goes enough samcoat Sky
News